americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 60.
can you believe it 60 days since joe
biden abandoned our fellow citizens our
friends their families our allies in the
islamic emirates of afghanistan and he
has not mentioned these hostages held by
the taliban that can't get out in over
40 days the ones that he said 13 days
before he abandoned him that he wouldn't
abandon now breaking tonight we have a
fox news alert the biden administration
will now reportedly allow certain afghan
citizens once employed by the brutal
terrorist taliban before 2001 they are
now welcome to travel to the united
states free of all terror restrictions
even though the taliban is a terrorist
organization
i'm sure that will have no consequences
at all right um does he not remember 9
11 they were at war with us we weren't
at war with them
sadly tonight afghanistan is only one of
many self-inflicted disasters all caused
by joe biden and all of them preventable
this week more horrendous economic news
another month of record-setting
inflation we're now at a 30-year
inflation high september now marks the
fifth straight month with inflation over
five percent we have a guy on the
atlanta fed said no this is here to stay
this is real might go into deep into
2022 and and further if it's possible
add to this america's supply chain is in
a complete state of meltdown and chaos
energy prices are now reaching 10 year
highs again self-inflicted staffing
shortages now it's plaguing major
industries all across the country but
don't worry joe biden he says he has it
all under control now he wants to
increase the bureaucracy and taxes on
business and he's telling business to
come in and bail him out pretty
interesting dichotomy there take a look
back in february
i signed a piece of legislation on
supply chain
executive order
on supply chains i'm joined by the
executive director of the ports of los
angeles and
long beach
gene soroca and uh and mario
mario cordono
uh
i miss i apologize
mario
and i especially want to thank joe
percari
uh and uh i i think
joe's done one heck of a job my special
envoy specifically on ports the world
has changed
prior to the crisis
we cheered and you know the focus on
lean efficient supply chains
oh excuse me i'm acting like joe
that does not inspire confidence in
anybody can barely speak at this point
joe took zero questions as per usual
then immediately retired for the day yup
you got it 3 30 pm lid per usual no
responsibility for the economic crisis
he has caused his policies have caused
and why would he this is what joe biden
himself promised he would do remember
the biden bernie manifesto oh it was
very clear we we outlined it before the
election nearly a year ago this was all
by design let's take you back in history
not very long ago it was 2019. here's
joe biden vowing to sacrifice jobs and
wreck the oil and gas industry all in
the name of that's right climate change
remember this
would you be willing to sacrifice some
of that growth
even knowing potentially that it could
displace thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of blue-collar workers in the
interest of transitioning to that
greener economy the answer is yes
the answer is yes if we don't stop using
its fuels
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't or
when they're deliberate put them in jail
that's what i'm from i'm not joking
i'm not joking i won't put oil execs in
jail the people
it's the lifeblood of the world's
economy if you find a cheaper cleaner
form of energy i'm in i'm all the above
but until then oil gas and coal it's the
lifeblood of the world's economy now
those were among the few promises joe
biden actually kept in january he halted
immediately the keystone xl pipeline all
while giving that hostile actor from
that hostile regime vladimir putin of
russia a brand new pipeline to western
europe so he can supply the energy to
our allies
and americans got pink slips he stopped
oil and gas exploration in parts of
alaska like anwar other federal lands
now he's begging opec and other foreign
countries to produce more oil by the way
they gave us an answer
no you should be asking texas and
oklahoma and north dakota and alaska and
then we can get all the energy we want
because we have more natural resources
than the entire middle east combined oil
and gas prices now through the roof all
caused by joe biden natural gas
he's making vladimir putin rich again
it's up 112 since january oil prices are
up a whopping 65
heating costs are set to soar just in
time for winter some families may be
paying a thousand dollars or more extra
that'll be the joe biden heating tax the
federal government said it expects
american households to see their heating
bills jump as high as 54
okay do the math gas and diesel prices
already at a 10-year high because he
artificially reduced the supply in the
world the demand remained constant and
guess what that does to prices oh you
don't need an mit or a harvard business
degree demand remains constant you
reduce the supply like joe did prices go
through the roof fossil fuels are the
lifeblood of the world's economy i'm an
all the above guy you give me something
better and cheaper i'll take it but you
don't have it yet everything you buy
everything that is manufactured yes it
relies on oil and gas to get it to the
store so you get to pick it off the
shelf and go pay for or check it out
yourself now everything you buy is more
expensive to make matters worse we have
a labor shortage now wrecking america's
supply chain and now not only is
everything more expensive but also it
might take months to arrive in the mail
in other words your christmas
president's presents for your kids it
may not arrive on time or even at all
but according to jan saki it's not her
problem circle back on this jen take a
look
over time as the economy was turning
back on we'd see some of these
transitory effects that's what we that's
what's been predicted
that's what we are have been planning
for
and of course next year we expect it to
come down can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee the american
people are of course impacted by
rising prices of gas in some parts of
the country not all we all understand
the american people are not looking at
cost to cost comparisons from this year
to two years ago they're looking at cost
to cost comparisons to their checkbooks
from eight months ago or 12 months ago
and even though factually if you look
back to two years ago things may be
comparative that's not how people look
at things uh yes it is gas prices are up
everywhere by the way jen just do a
little reading and research and i guess
you're going to tell those kids oh
you'll get your christmas presents next
year the one santa didn't leave you this
year because they didn't arrive in the
mail oh okay and you're not ups and
you're not fedex there is a massive
supply chain crisis caused in part
because of a lack of workers and that
brings us to biden's vaccine mandate and
that's only making things worse half of
chicago's police force
may now soon be forced to go on leave
now we look at the military we may lose
thousands of of our military brave men
and women that are willing to put their
lives on the line for our freedoms
because of joe's mandate hundreds of
airlines employees they are facing
termination thousands of teachers now
get this we may lose thousands of health
care workers
including all of those nurses and front
line health workers that in the
beginning of covet every day they walked
into a petri dish to save their fellow
americans lives many of them even got
covert they have what's called natural
immunity and by the way the nurses did
they dove on on covet grenades every day
and you want to just dismiss them and
fire them because they're getting fired
or will be fired in coming weeks state
employees federal employees members of
the military employees at large private
corporations all face termination if
they don't comply with biden's vaccine
mandate so jen circle back talk to joe
if he's awake how is this going to help
america's economic recovery and what
about the democrats new proposal to
empower the irs they want to comb
through your bank account they now want
to monitor transactions every one of
them over 600 bucks
everything you buy all the money you
transfer over six hundred dollars
democrats want to know about every
aspect of your life you give six hundred
dollars to your son or daughter the
democrats need to know about it you've
been mo 600 to a friend they need to
know about it you buy a chair for 600
bucks the democrats want the irs to know
all about it oh that's why that's right
they're spending nearly 100 billion
dollars for the irs why so they can
figure out a way to to tax and squeeze
you dry by the way welcome to my world
that is the world where you get audited
every year even though you pay all your
taxes and i advise everyone pay your
taxes it's stupid not to green new deal
socialism is not cheap and so they're
looking for new creative ways to pay for
this even though they say it won't cost
us a penny that doesn't make sense
either this will of course hurt low and
middle come in middle-income americans
they will be hurt the most just like
inflation just like supply shortages in
joe biden's america the middle class and
the poor are paying the price literally
joe biden's radical socialist agenda is
trump's everything no pun intended and
the polls now for joe have never been
worse he has more polls in the 30s and
well barack obama had it this time or
donald trump joe biden's valiant
protectors the medium mob they're now
falling on the sword they're they're
blaming themselves for biden's poor
performance lion brian humpty dumpty the
whole blue check media mob cult on
twitter take a look
how much should biden and the people
around him
be worried about these polling numbers
and here's a free shot how much of it is
the result of really crappy reporting by
mainstream news media the idea you know
biden says every every conversation
becomes a confrontation like there is
some truth to that concern i'm sure he's
watching and getting frustrated by
coverage of the dc budget battle sure
there is some truth to that
there were dead bodies floating in front
of my hotel which wasn't flooded okay
we're going to listen to them so the
media mob they're now saying we we're
probably being too hard on joe and and
maybe nancy pelosi is right we got to do
a better job of selling joe's new green
deal socialism at least one person on
cnn is warning that joe biden is leading
the democrats off a political cliff i
don't often agree but he's right here
take a look
i think that right now um you know the
honeymoon's over
there was a moment where it's like
trump's you know goodbye trump hello
vaccines we're so glad to see you joe
biden the problem is that he
put himself in a position where he made
big bold claims about the rest of the
agenda you think this great stuff that
we did is good it's nothing wait until
this summer when you're going to get all
this other stuff and then he steps on a
rake and then he slips on a banana peel
and he falls down the stairs with some
marbles right now the democratic party
is looking over the edge of a cliff and
there's a lot of fear and concern and we
you're not seeing that strong joe biden
leadership that i think people were
expecting
uh i was not expecting it it's worse
than i thought i knew it was going to be
bad uh yeah i and by the way why don't
we ever remind people notice fake news
cnn msdnc remember all during the trump
years they had up how many people had
covert contracted it how many people
died how many people were hospitalized
more people died in 2021 from covert
than 2020.
labor data labor day 300 percent
increase from election year last year
why doesn't the media put those little
signs on the corner of their you know
the lists up every day because they're
biased joe biden is not capable of
strong leadership i don't think he knows
what day of the week it is he's not even
really in charge we all know that
instead biden does the bidding of the
radical left of which he's a part of
they are in charge and now we are seeing
a taste of that green new deal socialism
firsthand it is not a pretty picture
here now with reaction hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else